this holiday season you can give the
gift of a steak Haitian I just really
wanted to say that thanks to Echo and
rig whether you want to dine in or take
home one of their butcher in a box gifts
they have you covered and here to tell
us more is Chef Sam Marvin thank you so
much for being here Jillian what a
pleasure to be here I'm so excited
thanks for having me well as Mercedes
and I said we love your restaurant and
you guys are growing and expanding and
doing so much but let's jump right to it
tell us what you created so butcher in a
box you know I go and I visit these
ranches I go as far as Tasmania to look
at the grass-fed cattle which is amazing
best grass in the world right and I go
to Kansas and I look at corn fed and I'm
visiting all these ranches and you don't
really see it I don't the people in the
house they don't really have a chance to
get the meat that I get so I said you
know what imagine if somebody else can
grab this meat from Tasmania or from
Creekstone farms in Kansas as opposed to
just going and buying meat right so
really what we're trying to do is
educate it's an experience it's not just
selling meat like these are steaks that
you know fillets and rib eyes and and
and hangers and bevettes and so many
different tomahawks and everyone's a
different state from a different Ranch
and it's the quality of it is amazing
right it just you feel it when you eat
it absolutely anytime I'm in your
restaurant the food is delicious so I
trust you to give us the best of the
best this is such a good idea and so the
idea here is that you can you know
subscribe to these boxes just get the
meat right to your house and I want to
jump right in and have you show us
something you can do sure and you get
recipes and swag
so you know what I'm doing now it's like
steak tartare we saw so many of them at
the restaurant right and I've never been
to a house where people actually do
steak tartar as a little appetizer so I
just take our meat right this is a
knuckle meat which is great it's not
really from the knuckles just called the
knuckle it actually comes closer to like
the knees and stuff like that and I give
it a nice rough chop right because steak
tartar you want to taste the steak right
especially especially this right this is
beautiful grass-fed beautiful flavor I
don't really really chop it too much I
give it a nice chew and I go into a bowl
I'm going to take a little bit that I
already had here right super simple it
was already just pre-cut and then I had
my ingredients I add a little bit of
jalapeno yeah so you know some people
like a little kick right these are
cornichons the little French gherkins so
I just chop them up so they're not
little big chunks looks great a little
bit of chives look at all this flavor
right a little bit of olive oil a lot of
people use a little bit of egg in there
and things like that salt and pepper a
little Pinterest right and a little bit
of fresh lemon juice look how easy
you're making this look and we are and
look at this this is going to be the
most beautiful luscious
meet first steak tartare I'm just in awe
I'm gonna just go like that I'm gonna
put it in a little bowl and as you're
cleaning this really quickly we have to
wrap up here soon but I love your
location at Tivoli Village because
they're expanding we are we're moving
into the district oh my God the district
is in
uh Green Valley Ranch right over there
in Green Valley Ranch in Henderson and
we are so excited we're gonna open right
around New Year's Eve maybe the first of
the year second third somewhere in that
neighborhood perfect and uh yeah we're
so excited the neighborhood has been the
community's been so great to us and it's
gonna be Echo rig 2.0 so the same style
Steakhouse but everything will be new
because we're 10 years old already it's
time for the new right all right we're
excited for the new congratulations be
sure to stop by Echo and rig and we're
just so happy for everything you guys
are doing Mercedes I'll send it